العام الاكثر سخونه بتاريخ الارض كان هذا
عام
20022 بحسب ناسه العام الماضي وجاتوه الحر
الشديد في الولايات المتحده واوروبا
الفيضانات المدمره في باكستان نيجيريا
السودان وغيرها ملايين المتضررين من عام
من زاد فيه الاحتباس قسوه لكن ما ينزل به
العام الجديد بيناير ادافع النسبيا غير
مسبوق استهلته اوروبا بمظاهر الشابه نتجت
عن ارتفاع الحراره ثمانيه درجات عن
المعدلات الطبيعيه
منتجعات التزلج في جبال الالب همم اغلقت
بسبب قله الثلوج وهناك من يستمتع في
الشواطئ على شواطئ اسبانيا وايطاليا اذا
الصيف يحمل توقعات اسوا ليس قعد الساعه 60
بل تاكيدات علماء المناخ لكن لماذا
الاجابه في النينو ظاهره مناخيه ستزيد
الطينه بالله تحدث عندما تصبح المياه في
شرق المحيط الهادئ الاستوائيه دافيئه بشكل
غير طبيعي اللي تؤثر على دوران الغلاف
الجوي العالمي هي تحدث كل بضع سنوات كانت
المره الاخيره في 2016 غير انها هذا العام
قد ترفع درجه حراره الارض الى الدرجه غير
المرجوئه فماذا لدينا من خيارات الان
وماذا نملك من ادوات التعايش ولا شيء اخر
لكن التعايش لا يعني الاهمال هناك ستبير
تدبير التكيف مثل جعل البنيه التحتيه اكثر
مقاومه لتاثيرات المناخ مقاومه للفيضانات
مثلا لكن ماذا لو لم يحرك ساكنه لو وقفت
الدول متفرقه تجيء بقى الشركات ديلوي تابي
بدراسه الصادمه لكن دقيقه الاقتصاد
العالمي سيتكبد تكاليف
278 تريليون دولار بحلول عام 2070 تكلفه
بشريه
ناتجه عن نقص الغذاء الماء وفقدان الوظائف
وتدهور الصحه والرفاهيه وفي المقابل العمل
المناخي يمكن ان يحقق ثلاثه واربعين
ترليون دولار من صافي القيمه الحاليه دي
عباره اخرى اذا تحركنا الان فسنحقق مكسباي
اتحول الاقتصادي والحد من الاثار الكارثيه
لتغيير المناخ